that's why I want to thank you we did
week shows a comic-con this summer and
we shall cold opening where I played the
old the woman who turns into an old hag
from Game of Thrones
Conan Sandra yeah and I exactly and I go
and I turn into the old hag and you're
the bellboy who keeps that I'm going to
bed and you keep interrupting me and you
were making me laugh so hard we were
trapped together for hours and I was
just crying laughing so hard just to be
told like Conan is tired wants to go to
bed has turned into an old hag and you
have to just annoy him and keep him up
is super fun yeah yeah and there's so
much we cut out so much stuff that was
hilarious
that never saw the light of day because
there was too much of it there was
literally was just hours and hours and
hours of you annoying me yes delightful
my favorite part of that is that that
was an actual hotel that was up and
running and there were guests staying
there yes and so at some point that you
and I I'm dressed like a bellhop from
the 30s you're dressed like a 6,000 year
old hag and we're just strolling down
the hallway and people are going to
their rooms just deciding to polish off
the rest of the minibar because the end
times are coming yeah we have we have
outtakes and I want to show these these
are so quick look at the outtakes this
is stuff that didn't make it take six
can I interest you in the water well
okay now I feel like what do you Bill
Cosby my cousin runs this frisbee golf
place and it's two-for-one with these
vouchers Swiss milk chocolate with honey
and almond nougat in my opinion it's the
honey that really makes the difference I
just thought you looked a little tired
you might want some 5-hour energy I'm
gonna pass
I'm sure because you smell a little like
death shower maybe a shower and a bath
little brood you know I'm getting the
white yeah yeah here okay in my book
because I started out liking you but now
I'm feeling less so huh that's weird to
be that bellboy it feels good to be in a
little pill hat like that feels good
you